we're gonna go a little clown my hound
boys okay now these are my seasonal
hounds because I want to see some
Halloween house we put some [ __ ]
horns on a howl or something dude yeah I
want to see haunt my aunt dude I want to
see smell I always see a clown in
blackface let's go here am buzz-buzz
knees laughter cigars bro it's the Black
Lung laughter Cubans bye babe this is
Remy oh my god Remy's up furry if I've
ever seen one
Remy's book been at apparently EDC all
weekend yeah still licking his face yeah
Remy just did a stint in [ __ ] Vegas
yeah roulette shot eyes Remy looks like
an idea rod dog if carrot top was the
driver of the sled uh Remy's been
through some stuff huh
yeah want to Jeremy pivens [ __ ]
buddies or a girl breaking a fire claim
um yeah Remy had bloodshot eye
Remy needs sleeve yeah bro Remy need to
nap and take the [ __ ] wig off yeah
Remy looks like he was an oil spill and
kind of liked it you know he looks like
the kind of dog that'll take a couple of
a couple tabs of X and jump in the oil
spill
yeah Remy seems like he's coming down
off the X and he's super depressed yeah
Remy's been at Coachella all weekend
yeah and first of all dressed up like a
unicorn did it means a lot of horses are
coming at you with them big wieners bro
dude don't keep touching me session time
horizontally all I know is Remy needs a
break yeah what else do we know about
Ray me anything we don't know anything
much about Remy other than he's a
unicorn and the owners came to your show
and you told the lady that you had a
mullet above your dick I did that's what
you said well I mean she was also gang
gang buzz-buzz
right but if she's also peddling these
types of animals you know who met what
kind of animals mate to make this little
Remy
I don't know what kind of dogs it's a
good point they didn't say yeah this
looks like this looks like am I like a
mouse you would find in a V cheese house
you know this thing looks like it's been
through some stuff yeah it's Viking the
unicorn yeah this looks like a uh oven
mitt it Diplo's you know this looks like
it's like a stuffed toy of Steve Aoki's
house this thing looks like it's been a
sex slave somewhere maybe on Saturn or
something
this looks like Brendan's the sheriff
this looks like his little frickin
deputy right here yeah that's my hand
that's my canine get it Ramy go and
sniff that X out that ax out thank you
for sending this dog in it looks like a
beautiful animal I think you definitely
have to get it uh some vitamin B
injectables though it needs some b12
fast yeah so it needs a IV no next we
got Paisley and arrow
Paisley ripping that King and the
stingrays huh
okay buzz buzz daddy's me and Thea
that's me on the right and CEO status
[ __ ] on the left his that is that two
bees though now I love these costumes
now this is beautiful animal hell yeah
beautiful animal and on the left looks
like seeing some [ __ ] this beautiful
animal is right here but the one on the
left is one of his definitely a beat
have the wings but one of them got just
the stripes one just has a turtleneck on
it's two bees those two bees no buzz
buzz double buzz oh that one looks like
it would definitely catch a frisbee uh
you know or catch a couple steak
medallions or something you know one on
the left looks like you eat all is honey
well yeah the one on the left he's sad
because he's blind in one eye after
being attacked by a 90 pound dog oh
that's me that's me that always been
some [ __ ] damn with a dog took his eye
out and the other ones mess that I was
just blinding it man what does it say
about the other one here oh it says the
other one struggled in school and also
makes a lot of poor dietary choices
oh that's Brendon
that's the brennaman that's us dude
that's us man good to see you
buzz-buzz dude nice to know we'll be
reincarnated in some happy home looks
like a beautiful area
it doesn't make you nice little home
thank you for sending in paisley an
arrow
dem dogs right there dude up next we got
this one's awesome this is miss Tootie
pinched damn seems like she's gonna yell
at me to get a pumpkin spice latte oh
look at the pumpkin spice body on that
thing huh
and that hound is bodied oh those
[ __ ] little thought feelers has
little arms dude yeah I think looks like
when you get a cheap uh chicken wing and
that you know if you get a Buffalo Wild
Wing
yeah if you get that [ __ ] rainbow rub
that's this thing looks like look at
those little legs those little [ __ ]
bracelets for legs man but what is this
is a chihuahua this is a six year old
Chihuahua mix full of sass and he bites
a lot yeah and the mom is a dog groomer
and he's at the shop every day and all
the products on the animal are
plant-based and chemical free from what
plan yeah whatever that's what night
details I know a plan a chemical plant
yeah this dog looks like something Elton
John they pulled out of Elton John's
stomach this thing what how did they get
that much stuff on it yeah how the [ __ ]
did they diet so many times this thing
like looks like if it bit you then like
male porn huh but you just open up on
your phone like I feel this thing very
erotic or exotic Brendon this thing
knows its art tell you that much and you
sure it's a dog I think it looks it
looks like it's almost bred to small
sometimes you get those dogs that are so
small they're just freezing the whole
time and they're scared other
constitution yeah and they're putting
lipstick on they don't know what to do
they're not even really dogs it's kind
of in that imposition attics they're in
the other side down yeah that is
addicted they want more you know body
and legs and arms but they don't have
they didn't give them nobody can't get
it
have genetics oh I thought that was the
leash on the far right but that's his
hair they spiked up like alfalfa mmm now
I do at the end he does look pretty like
he should be like he's gonna move to uh
you know maybe San Francisco or
something well San Francisco tree on the
right there's a lot of kids and rappers
that dress like that these days
oh yeah he does look like a little uh
whatever his name is little diazepam or
something yeah yeah whatever that guy's
name is a little Tylenol little onion
yeah I can't remember that guy's uh I
don't know any of them dudes er Tech or
something I do die I do took like mm you
know a little I can't remember his name
was little claritin little claret and
yeah I do [ __ ] sneeze and his whole
body blew up yeah so a lot of these boys
on pills man yeah it's on pills bro look
here's what I say if a frisbee will kill
it it's not a dog so I'm not even
accepting this thing as a damn animal
not under a frisbee and it [ __ ] ends
this thing's life son and then ain't an
animal of the Lord no that's a fancy
rank you know my face yeah this thing is
this is state this is one of Satan's
little side pieces man and you can put
this thing back in a biscuit maker
mother pan whatever color you want to
think Satan's work we got to stand up
for these animals with you bro people
submit and rats trying to pass one over
bias we too smart for that
yeah you look dressed like [ __ ] so
don't get it twisted oh I look nice a
thing yeah I think you'd best you're my
wings so glowing or not
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]